this is a production of Cornell
University hi everyone my name is Janice
Vegard and I'm a PhD student in a
section of horticulture today I'm kind
of talking about one of my last projects
in my dissertation and quite frankly one
I'm still working through a little bit
if you're at the SIPPs recruitment
weekend's this is a repeat so my
apologies
however I appreciate any feedback that
you might have from the project I work
with dr. Phillip Griffiths in Geneva and
an applied vegetable breeding program
and he worked on a variety of different
crops but we focus primarily on Nebraska
crops including broccoli and cabbage and
for my dissertation specifically I've
been focused on on the leafy brassicas
which includes the popular kale and
collard and when I first arrived to our
breeding program I was pretty quite
frankly overwhelmed by the diversity
that we had when it came to consumer and
kind of end-user quality traits I was
looking at the leafy Brassica germ plasm
in our program and I looked at the
variety of more leaf morphologies and
sizes and colors and quite frankly it
felt pretty chaotic to me I didn't
really understand how to contextualize
it within a market setting or in within
a market context and I still to this day
even after a few years have questions
about how we introduce some of that
diversity for my breeding program into
markets which forms from our breeding
program might resonate with consumers
and then also how we kind of sidestep
already inherent biases like any
consumers or end-users might already
have due to prior product familiarity if
that makes sense so there's all my
philosophical questions for today but to
kind of organize the plant material and
my brain to some extent what I did in
2017 was develop a dial of mating design
is a common breeding mating scheme
that's used typically to understand the
genetic underpinnings of quantitative
traits but this I thought that I could
apply this breeding scheme in the
context of consumer preference and so
what I did was I went back to our germ
plasm and I kind of selected leave types
that were readily distinct and distinct
enough so that we could almost call them
different market classes and I ended up
with eight different market classes so
you can kind of see like an iconic curly
kale you can see like a Collard and a
Tuscan and then there's also types I
don't really have a name yet
what I did with these eight different
parents and market classes is that I
cross them and all possible across
combinations to develop a hybrid progeny
set and those hybrids are essentially
complements of each of the parents but
you can use this design to identify
useful combinations using performance
estimates and you can also kind of gauge
the the breeding value in some ways of
the parental types too and their
usefulness in your breeding program so
you can look at it at a very specific
level across by cross level or you could
kind of look at the general breeding
value of each parent in multiple crosses
too and so I say we use performance
estimates but you like performance
estimates of what and this is where the
consumer preference sets in and so what
I did with all of these progeny and the
parents was that I image them and I put
them into an online survey format and so
I'll be distributing an online consumer
preference survey in a balanced and
complete block design to a large number
of consumers asking two primary
questions one is how much do you prefer
or how much do you like this leaf type
and then how familiar is it to you have
you seen it before
and then it can also go through the
survey ask other questions about
demographics or consumption patterns to
kind of get an idea of who's
participating in the study - um so
that's the main focus of this online
survey but I can also use this dial and
lots of other other settings so I've
regenerated all the seed this winter for
field you know typing this summer and
fall and then I've also just got back
some genotyping by sequencing data that
will begin to give us just a brief
introduction into some of the genetic
architecture of any of the traits that
we do phenotype and it also helped us
understand some of the population
structure within our program because it
really hasn't been evaluated thus far
from a genetic perspective but really
what I expect to see are some of the
outcomes yes clarity right hopefully at
the end of this dissertation some
clarity comes along but what am i
working hypotheses is that those those
parents that have hide you know genetic
combining general combining ability a
rate that performed well from that
perspective
are also highly correlated with familiar
so that is people were highly preferring
those types that they think that they
already knew that makes any sense
so like an iconic curly kale type would
likely rate pretty highly but that's one
of my working hypotheses and then any
any that perform well from a specific
combining ability perspective might
provide incentive for diversity or a
really novel new variety or something
like that but really this project is
meant to guide our breeding program and
help us understand what leaf
characteristics might be important to
consumers in the future thank you I'll
take any questions any questions right
so um I question was have I incorporated
any flavor characteristics so a lot of
my previous work has been in conjunction
with the sensory evaluation center so
just wrapped up a multi-year study kind
of evaluating flavor and quality from a
qualitative standpoint from and from a
quantitative standpoint and there's a
diverse amount of flavor characteristics
we could look at but this will just
tackle the appearance appearance
component which is also one of the first
kind of introductions any consumer has
to a new product oh I don't think I get
naming rights I mean I guess I haven't
talked to the Gryff about it but I think
we have across combination beach between
like a yellow cabbage collards it's a
really light looking leaf type and then
we've got a deep purple colored leaf
type as well that is a result of
selection for increased anthocyanins as
part of a natural color project but
across those two and we get a really
pigmented vein with a nice contrasting
weak type so I think that would be my
favorite maybe call it sunset or
something
that's the other creative Department
[Applause]
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu